>>> IN OUR WORLDDAY
PRESIDENT BIDEFFIS
TRUNCAD TO MEET
WITH FELLOW WOLEAT THE
Y A SHARP
FOCUS ON
AGGROND ON
RUSSIAAGAINST
BUT AS PRESIDENT BIDEN SHAKES WD
NE AMERICAN
FAMILYUR BIDEN
TO THEIR ANOTHERUE
THEIR ASKINGSI BS RDN JAPAN'S P
MINISTERUM KHI
LIEUTENANT WHO'S IMPRISONED
BAR JAPAN
R NEARLY 100 DAYS, PART OF A
THREE YEAREN
REGLIGENT DRIVING DEATHS
OF TWO CITIZENS. BECAME UNCONSCD
WHEEAND THATO THTRIC
DEAD C
JOINING TH CEMIND OUR
AND Y 29 AY YOU THINS ENTENCE II
ERHE LOSSNESS.WOA CRASENTH HIM.
TRAGED
HE S
FAMILY WAS T COF, T MAINTAINED
NEVER TIRE ASKED HE T FALLAND T
THATUGO YOUR HBAYOU A
WEU
SHARED WITH US.
I WANT TO READAR
M  GOOD.
THE WALLS AND BA
C.
MEETINU.R TOO MY SMATH 3NU
A HUMAN BEING RIGHT NOW.JUST A
YON WHEN YOU
BRITTANEN, I'VEIM
GS T,
WITH A GOOTIANR HIS SPIRT
AND ALSO IT MAS ME MAD.
>> YEAH.
KNOW, IDE B THEY'RE HURTHEY T .
WE TALK ABOUHE TIME.SKE THR  SA,
I ING TOIXT.
BUT THEY'R KIDS.
KNOW, THEY'RE DOING THE ST.U --
SLTOSCUSSION YOU H WPRR HIS "STE
FEBRUARYRO P
GING
YOU. NAV PO,BSOLUTELY NOT.NG BK
AGAINST US.
>> I, YOU'VE ACC TNG A WHISPER
O
CONVINOM THAT YOUR
TRIAL IN JAPANSAE-OUICIALS AUSH
>> K E-MAILSIN CREEMENT VIOLATIT
MEMBERS  CS.TTF SOME OTH HAVE GA
LD IS  QWITH
SAID. THINGSNUE TO BE FALSE ANDE
RS JAPANS IMPORTANT.I DOOTHAT WN
NJIMPRISONUR NAV